of the stars of the big game aside from
the game itself is the food and
stk is ready to help executive chef
stephen hopcraft is here to talk about
the stk las vegas big game viewing party
we were just talking about how the wing
is king and i'm looking at some of these
dishes
that stk brought here talk about some of
the spread you're gonna have for the big
game party
oh i know and that's just a little bit
but first of all welcome to las vegas
uh that's the cosmopolitan at las vegas
at stk we're
really happy to have you tuning in to
see what we're going to do for the big
game this game is going to be super and
the food's got to be super to follow
so one of my favorites is pigs in a
blanket i like to call it pigs
wellington
just to kind of fancy it up but i'll
tell you what you dip that in some honey
mustard
one of my favorite sauces because the
recipe is right there in the sauce honey
mustard here we go i'm trying it right
now
and you're gonna have you're gonna have
yourself a good weenie
when it comes when it comes to steak
though i think that's what we really
pride ourselves
so we thought we'd put a little steak on
your table as you watch the big game
uh and have a little fries some dipping
sauces
and that's our new york which is
personally pound for pound my favorite
steak in the restaurant
uh you can see we did it nice and
mid-rare plus right there
a pile of fries and uh that's the way
you root on your favorite team
well we know that sdk is the king of
snakes and you guys are gonna have quite
the party this year tell us about it
you've got the food you've got
the alcohol you've got the game how much
does it cost how do people get in
uh it's just over 300 but uh that comes
with
free appetizers i mean not free but
obviously all you can eat appetizers
all you can drink so we got a lot of
stuff going on and you're going to be
sitting here for four hours
we've got over 22 tvs so everybody gets
a view
and you know there's not going to be a
lot of people in here because you know
we are definitely
adhering to social distancing and the
whole nine so it's going to be a safe
fun way to enjoy a big game well of
course if they can't make it for the big
game you also have valentine's day
coming up and
i know you guys have some great specials
for that too we only have a couple of
minutes left but how do they get in
touch with you guys
well you can you can get on the
cosmopolitan website and
and that'll hook you right up to a great
date at sdk
if you really want to impress her fellas
come here and see me
absolutely thank you guys so much check
out the incredible menu at stk for the
big game or any night at the
cosmopolitan las vegas
jc over to you